ITSELF DOING THE PASSPORTS.
>> DR. MICHAEL OSTERHOLM, THANK
YOU.
>>> NEW YORK CITY POLICE ARE
INVESTIGATING TWO BRUTAL NEW
ATTACKS ON ASIAN AMERICANS.
THERE IS VIDEO.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S COMING NEXT.
WE NEED TO WARN YOU IT'S
DISTURBING.
BOTH ATTACKS ARE REPORTED AS
HATE CRIMES AND PART OF A
DISTURBING TREND DURING THIS
PANDEMIC.
NANCY CHEN HAS MORE ON THE
STORY.
>> Reporter: IN SURVEILLANCE
VIDEO TAKEN FROM AN APARTMENT
BUILDING THE 65-YEAR-OLD ASIAN
WOMAN IS SEEN WALKING BEFORE A
MAN SUDDENLY APPEARS AND
VIOLENTLY STRIKES HER CAUSING
HER TO FALL TO THE GROUND.
HE THEN REPEATEDLY STOMPS HERE,
STRIKING HER MULTIPLE TIMES TO
THE HEAD BEFORE CAUSALLY WALKING
AWAY.
A NEARBY SECURITY GUARD INSIDE
THE BIDDING APPEARS TO DO
NOTHING WHILE THE BRUTAL ATTACK
OCCURRED.
THE STAFF WHO WITNESSED THE
ATTACK HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED
PENDING AN INVESTIGATION.
ACCORDING TO THE MANAGEMENT
COMPANY.
POLICE SAY THE ATTACKER MADE
ANTI-ASIAN STATEMENTS TOWARDS
THE WOMAN.
OUR NEW YORK STATION WCBS
REPORTED THE MAN SHOUTED "YOU
DON'T BELONG HERE" BEFORE
RUNNING AWAY.
THE WOMAN IS HOSPITALIZED WITH
SERIOUS INJURIES AND POLICE ARE
STILL LOOKING FOR THE SUSPECT.
THE NEW YORK POLICE DEPARTMENT'S
HATE CRIME UNIT IS ALSO
INVESTIGATING THIS ATTACK ON A
ATTACK POLICE BELIEVE IS ASIAN.
SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEO SHOWS THE MAN
BEING PUMMELED ON THE SUBWAY
BEFORE BEING PLACED IN A CHOKE
HOLD BY HIS ATTACKER AND LEFT
UNCONSCIOUS.
POLICE ARE STILL TRYING TO TRACK
DOWN THE SUSPECT AND THE VICTIM.
NATIONALLY, MORE THAN 3500 HATE
INCIDENTS TOWARD ASIAN AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN RECORDED SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO ONE ADVOCACY
GROUP.
>> IT'S REALLY TERRIBLE HOW
EVERY SINGLE DAY THERE SEEMS TO
BE ANOTHER INCIDENT.
>> Reporter: DOZENS GATHERED IN
NEW YORK CITY MONDAY NIGHT FOR A
CANDLELIGHT VIGIL HONORING THE
VICTIMS IN THE ATLANTA AREA SPA
SHOOTINGS WHERE SIX ASIAN WOMEN
WERE KILLED, FOR SOLIDARITY OF
ALL VICTIMS OF HATE.
>> WE'RE JUST STARTING TO LEARN
HOW TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING TO US FOR
AS LONG AS WE CAN REMEMBER.
>> Reporter: NEW YORK POLICE SAY
35 ANTI-ASIAN HATE CRIMES SO FAR
THIS YEAR BUT THE DEPARTMENT
ADMITS HATE CRIMES AND CRIMES
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS HAVE
LONG GONE UNDERREPORTED.
STARTING THIS WEEK, UNDERCOVER
ASIAN AMERICAN COPS WALKING ON
THE STREETS TO HELP WITH
RESPONSE.
GAYLE.
>> NANCY, THANK YOU.
YOU LOOK AT THAT VIDEO, IT'S
ATROCIOUS.
I EXPECT MORE FROM A SECURITY
GUARD WHO APPEARED TO CLOSE THE
DOOR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PICTURE,
SOMEBODY KNOWS THOSE TWO GUYS.
SOMEBODY KNOWS THOSE TWO GUYS
NOW IS THE TIME TO TURN THEM IN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
>> SO MUCH AWARENESS ON THE
ATTACKS YOU WOULD THINK THAT
PEOPLE ARE REALLY THINKING ABOUT
THIS AND THESE ATTACKS WOULD
REDUCE.
NOT STILL HAPPEN.
>> I KNOW.
>> YOU SNOW WHAT'S SCARY, GUYS,
PEOPLE ARE SO AFRAID TO
INTERVENE.
THEY WOULD MUCH RATHER --
THEY'RE AFRAID FOR THEIR OWN
LIVES.
>>